one of nature's other creatures is the
firefly a soft-bodied beetle that emits
a warm yellow glow from its lower
abdomen typically at twilight in order
to attract mates or prey though
relatively rare in europe and north
america the firefly is a common sight in
japan where it is known as the hotaru
hotarus are at their most plentiful in
june and july and can be seen in groups
around rivers and lakes the glittering
light of the hotaru is deemed to be so
enchanting the japanese hold firefly
festivals or hotaru matsuri to watch
their dance
something even odder has happened to the
firefly in japan it has become
philosophical zen buddhist poets and
philosophers the two terms are largely
interchangeable in japan have over the
centuries noted the affinity between the
firefly and a central concept in zen the
brevity of life
zen does not think of our transients as
tragic rather it is by accommodating
ourselves gracefully to our own
evanescence that we can reach
enlightenment and harmony with nature's
necessities
for zen the firefly is the perfect
symbol of transients positively
interpreted its season is very brief it
lights up only in high summer and its
light is intermittent and flickering
fireflies are both fragile and
astonishingly beautiful when seen in
large numbers in a pine forest or a
meadow at night they are a metaphor for
our own poignant lives
the move of locating important
philosophical themes in the natural
world is one that zen makes again and
again for example in relation to bamboo
evocative of resilience water a symbol
of patient strength capable of wearing
down stone and cherry blossom an emblem
of modest rapture
zen repeatedly hangs its ideology onto
things that could seem at first very
minor because it wants to make use of
what is most ordinarily in our sight to
keep us tethered to its grand pathetic
truths
the great 17th century poet matsuo basho
pushes aside our day-to-day vanity and
egoistic ambitions in the hope that we
might become via his focus on a small
short-lived creature appropriately
attentive to our own finitude
falling from a blade of grass to fly off
a firefly
for zen buddhism the firefly is the
ideal carrier on its slender wings of
reminders of the need for dignified
resignation in the face of the
mightiness and mystery of the natural
order koyabashi issa an 18th century
buddhist priest as well as haiku master
wrote 230 poems on fireflies
in one of the most celebrated of these
he captures a moment where time is
momentarily stilled so that its passage
can more viscerally be felt
the fireflies are sparkling and even the
mouth of a frog hangs wide open
it's a tiny moment of satori or
enlightenment the frog is as
wonderstruck as the poet at the piercing
light of the brave doomed fireflies much
as we should fairly be amazed frightened
grateful and ultimately joyous to have
been allocated a few brief moments in
which to behold and try to make sense of
our own existence in an always largely
unfathomable 13.8 billion year old
universe
how to survive the modern world is a
guide to coping with the present it
explores why some key features of modern
life including capitalism advertising
mass media and the rise of individualism
can have harmful effects on our
psychological health